let's talk about the kidney and how
amazing it is and how to protect it and
exactly what you should be taking to
minimize any type of toxicity or damage
to the kidney especially long term the
kidney is actually very rugged it's
similar to the liver and that it can
take a beating but it can regenerate
each kidney is composed of roughly about
a million tiny little filters and these
kitties have to filter all day and all
night long 24 7 constantly and they
filter blood and so where does the Blood
come from well it comes from what you
eat right so all the food that you eat
all the junk food all the alcohol that
you drink all the medications and the
drugs that you're exposed to all the
pollution all the Plastics end up in the
blood and then they end up in the kidney
and your kidney just has to be able to
differentiate what it wants to recycle
and what it needs to get rid of so
there's a high degree of complexity
going on in this little filter called
the Nephron and as you age you start
losing these little filters to the point
where you can actually lose up to 20 of
your kidney okay they can shrink as you
age and so it becomes even more
important that as you age you really
start eating better and are exposed to
less toxins drugs and medications of
course that's just the opposite as we
age we take more medications and
unfortunately you know older people
especially if they end up in some type
of home are not eating
the right Foods the kidneys also make
certain hormones uh one being to make
red blood cells the other one is for
blood pressure but let's dive into some
things that really destroy the kidney
and there's even so-called healthy foods
that are destroying the kidney and we'll
talk about those as well let's first
talk about what makes up a kidney stone
right because having a kidney stone can
create a lot of damage to your kidney
especially because it has these little
crystals that can damage and create scar
tissue of the kidney itself as well as a
little tube that connects the kidney to
the bladder so kidney stones most
commonly come from what's called oxalate
Stones like calcium oxalate stones but
you can also get them in a form of uric
acid Stones as well one of the most
important things to do especially if
you're prone to kidney stones is to
limit the amount of oxalates that you're
exposed to and if you're on the
ketogenic plan uh chances are you're
probably eating something right now that
is very high in oxalates so almonds
spinach
beet tops peanuts grains beans sweet
potatoes cassava tapioca which comes
from cassava kiwi chocolate Swiss chard
turmeric has a good amount of oxalates
however turmeric has a lot of other
properties to help decrease inflammation
as well as prevent The Binding of
calcium and oxlets but also cinnamon is
a bit high in oxalates as well as clove
now the other point I want to mention
about these oxalates because they can
really create
some issues that go beyond just problems
in the kidney they can create arthritis
as well as something called pseudo gout
gout is normally created by this uric
acid crystal that's developing
but with pseudogao it's not uric acid
there's some other types of crystals
that are developing from calcium and
also can be worsened if you have high
levels of oxalates right either in the
diet or your body is just making them
one point about pseudogout is that
anything that increases the excretion of
too much calcium could worsen it okay
and interestingly enough uh too much
salt can cause a release of this calcium
from the kidneys so if you currently are
consuming a lot of salt and probably not
enough potassium you might want to just
make a change and see if that doesn't
help you because most of the population
you can handle a lot of salt but for a
select small group of people especially
if they have gout or even pseudogout
they might do better without excessive
salt I think really the big problem is
the ratio of potassium to sodium and if
you had enough potassium you know your
salt level would be fine but I would
just recommend playing around with the
dosage and start lowering the salt and
raising the potassium and see if you
don't feel better so by decreasing the
salt you're going to be excreting
calcium a lot less and it won't develop
into crystals the other interesting
point of about oxlets has to do with
malabsorption in your gut if you have
malabsorption and I'm talking about
damage in the gut let's say you have
inflammation you have Celiac or Crohn's
or irritable bowel syndrome gastric
bypass for example so there's a certain
level of damage in your digestive tract
that doesn't allow you to absorb certain
things especially fats
and if you're doing like the ketogenic
diet and or even carnivore and you have
all this fat that's coming into the gut
but you can't really absorb the fat some
of that fat is going to bind with the
calcium and that's going to leave the
oxlets free to be reabsorbed okay go
into your blood and end up in a kidney
so there is this interesting connection
between fat binding to calcium and then
freeing up this oxalate if you're eating
foods low in oxalates you'd have nothing
to worry about also another point about
that if you're eating foods high in
oxalates and you take more calcium with
it maybe through the dairy then you're
also protected so if you're going to do
some spinach dish and you had cheese
with it that might be helpful so that's
just another way to counter the damage
of these oxalates on the kidney since
the kidney can be very sensitive to Too
Much uric acid and oxalates when they
usually do a urine test
for people with gout or kidney stones
they usually always find that there's
excessive amounts of calcium in the
urine excessive amounts of uric acid
oxalates and there's also lower amounts
of this other thing called cetrates
Citrus now what are citrates well your
body makes them also you can get it from
consuming Citrus like lemons or limes
right and citrus is really interesting
because it actually binds with the
oxalates in a way that prevents the
calcium from binding and it can lower
your risk of getting kidney stones and
the thing about consuming lemons is that
they're alkaline that's one way to
counter gout if you have too much uric
acid so this is why lemons are really
good for that kidney okay they protect
the kidney there they have potassium in
there they provide some alkalinity but
they also protect against these oxalates
another interesting natural remedy would
be out apple cider vinegar take like a
tablespoon in your water in the morning
as a way to prevent Stones Let me just
kind of circle back to potassium again
and talk a little bit more about that
potassium is probably one of the best
minerals to protect the kidney and
people are so concerned about taking
potassium because they've heard
something that potassium is bad for the
kidney it's only bad if you have a stage
five kidney disease like end-stage
kidney disease where you would want to
take potassium but apparently even if
there is some damage of the kidney
potassium can be protective so since the
general population doesn't consume a lot
of potassium foods potassium in a like
electrolyte powder or just high
potassium foods are very very beneficial
for the kidney and they can help balance
it the sodium leafy greens large solids
avocados very very high in potassium
well but so are our beet leaves the beet
leaves are very high in oxide
so you want to consume
um vegetables that are high in potassium
but low in oxalates and so even though
spinach is very high in potassium you
wouldn't want to do it because it's high
in oxalates as well but there's other
things you can do to counter that damage
you can actually again have a little
cheese with that and that way it'll give
you the calcium to prevent some of those
Outlets from binding but I probably
didn't talk about the the most uh
damaging thing to your kidney which is
sugar okay because the number one cause
of end-stage kidney disease is diabetes
all right and that comes from a high
carb diet you know it's so interesting
if you look at the flips out of that the
ketogenic diet low carb you might hear
reports that oh the ketogenic diet is
really bad for your kidneys so you need
to avoid it because you might develop a
ketoacidosis and well first of all we're
always recommending the the healthy
version of the ketogenic diet so you're
not going to develop ketoacine doses
ketoacidosis occurs when you're a
diabetic and you forget to take your
insulin and you have super high levels
of acidity and ketones which you're
never going to see if you're not a
diabetic actually ketones are very
healthy for the kidney and a high carb
diet is not very healthy to the kidney
because you're exposing the kidney the
little filters with so much oxidation
and that's basically kind of rusting out
the kidney and then what happens is once
you destroy that filter then you start
seeing glucose in the urine because
we're not recycling it anymore and one
test to evaluate what's going on the
kidneys is actually to check your blood
like your waste product of protein is
called urea so it's called blood
urea nitrogen so with kidney disease
you'll see excessive amount of protein
in the urine which is not good but you
also see
urea or a waste product protein in the
blood but you also see another compound
called creatinine in the urine as well
in excessive amounts and that just
indicates there's another protein
problem with your muscles not being
handled by the kidney but creatinine can
also occur from other reasons as well
because when you like eat a lot of
cooked meat okay when you cook it you
actually convert creatine to creatinine
and that can show up in the urine as
well as consuming just large amounts of
protein but typically you're only going
to see a problem with that if your
kidneys are not healthy if your kidneys
are healthy and you're eating a lot of
protein I think you're not going to see
any problem in fact I really have not
found any really good evidence to show
that eating too much protein will do any
damage to the kidney it's usually when
someone's eating a lot of protein and a
lot of sugar at the same time but
creatinine can also show up if there's
liver damage or even as a side effect
from taking ACE inhibitors which are
medications for blood pressure or if
you're doing heavy duty exercise it can
show up so you have to be able to
differentiate is a kidney problem or is
it something else so let's just
summarize some of the things that you
can do to really keep these kidneys in
check I would do lemon water every
morning actual if you can squeeze a
lemon that would be best put it in the
water add your apple cider vinegar drink
your liquids it's probably a good idea
especially if you're prone to kidney
stones to consume two and a half liters
of water because kidney stone occurs
because there's a super saturated amount
of urine and you're getting all these
crystals developing so if you're
drinking enough liquids you're going to
be fine with that second point is to
avoid High oxalate type foods and of
course there's a lot more to talk about
that but I gave you the ones that are
like the most important and if you do
eat foods high in oxalates We'll add
some Dairy to it or add some calcium to
counter that and of course a really
important point is to go on the low carb
ketogenic plan with intermittent fasting
and also out of all the sugars fructose
by the way and I want to just add this
to the mix can really spike your uric
acid more than a lot of other things so
fructose is really really bad as in high
fructose corn syrup also when you're
consuming a lot of vitamin C and I know
there is some benefits of doing high
levels of vitamin C for certain things
but if you're trying to get rid of your
gout or your pseudo gout and you're
consuming massive amounts of vitamin C
in the form of ascorbic acid well just
make some changes cut that out for a
couple days and see if your pain doesn't
just go away I just wanted to in this
video include a lot of different links
to things that could be aggravating your
condition now let's say you are a
diabetic or you have kidney damage
already there are things you can do to
help protect the kidney even more in
addition to potassium and that would be
consuming a lot of the phytonutrients or
the antioxidants and certain plant Foods
especially in micro greens okay which
are these little baby plants they grow a
little bit more than Sprouts okay and
they're I recommend the ones grown in
soil if you can get them and the reason
I'm saying that is if you're consuming
like microgreens right compared to adult
vegetables you're going to get some of
these phytonutrients in levels that are
you know 20 50 to 100 times more than
the adult vegetables so all it takes is
a small amount of these things to create
a big effect and if you're trying to you
know protect the kidney this is very
doable it's very easy just add it to
your salad and it can help protect you
and I'm talking about the phytonutrients
like sulforaphane flavonoids carotenoids
even chlorophyll all of those are really
good to protect the kidney but just one
last point about that turmeric does have
high levels of oxalates so there's mixed
reviews on that powerful phytonutrient
now that you have that information if
you have not seen my video on the seven
warning signs of a toxic kidney I put
that up right here check it out